[Music]
adèle continues to wow us with her
traumatic weight loss the singer was
spotted in Los Angeles looking fitter
than ever in all black athletic gear
including a Nike bucket hat fans first
took notice that Adele was shedding
pounds when she shared a pic of herself
at Drake's birthday party back in
October then there were these pics just
before Christmas Adele showed off her
figure on Instagram in a black silk
dress in January a fan told People
magazine she ran into Adele on vacation
in Anguilla and according to the fan the
singer admitted to shedding 100 pounds
she stunned yet again with her
appearance at jay-z and Beyonce's Oscars
after-party with a snatched voice as she
rocked a sequin leopard print dress I've
never even thought about it at all it
only comes to my attention if I was to
read something about it I think everyone
else makes a bigger deal out of it but
that's kind of their job really does it
bother you no no in 2012 Adele spoke
with Anderson Cooper about how she felt
about the pressure to lose weight I've
never seen magazine covers and seen
music videos and been not I need to look
like that if I want to be a success but
it was this moment that sticks out most
McKee is the first we'll be happier
yourself she echoed this on her 31st
birthday captioning these photos i've
changed drastically in the last couple
years and I'm still changing and that's
okay it's been a complete roll room
adding learning to really truly love
yourself is it and I've only just
realised that that is more than enough
[Music]